with fellow journalist louise branson of
the recent book gorbachev heretic in the
kremlin
desco doter co-author of the new book
gorbachev heretic and the kremlin what
would we see if we were able to see mr
gorbachev behind the scenes that we
don't see on television
well like with any actor you would see
the real man
behind the facade is a man who is
right now is quite troubled
he's a different man from the guy
five years ago
when he took power
who
has grown quite a bit in in office
but who has also faced the
limitations of his power and
i think
must be a frustrating experience
how close have you been to him
i think
i mean i've asked questions of gorbachev
only in informal settings
he is a very private man i
had good fortune to
meet with a lot of of his close
people closest to him for a long period
of time
and talk and of course there's an
element of
geography in this because they always
say good things about the boss
but still you can you can get an element
of
you can get some insights from them what
makes this guide tick
and
the basic impulse on our part in doing
this book was to sort of understand who
this guy is
you know how did he come where you know
where did he come from
you know
out of nowhere practically i i
i've been in this business for a long
time and
even while i was in moscow for instance
in 1981
and
beginning of 82
i never really considered gorbachev to
be a
serious
pretender
so to speak
because
i know for instance one of the leading
american criminologists just published a
book in 1980
in which gorbachev's name appears once
so the guy really came out of nowhere
and
dazzled the world
he's a great adventurer
i mean he has taken his country in the
world an adventure and i we wanted to
figure out who's who this guy is what
makes him take when were you last
stationed in the soviet union i was
stationed there from 80 well the last
time i was for a long period i was from
81 to 85
but i've been last time i was this year
in february
and i've been in moscow every year at
least twice
since 85.
and when you were there
for the long period of time you were the
washington post washington post yes
then you were back with u.s news i went
for u.s news to moscow at least five
times i think once i went on my own just
to do the research you recently left u.s
news what are you doing
well i'm gonna
try to
make a living freelancing and doing
books
freelancing about what
we'll move to eastern europe and i think
where things are really happening in
eastern europe interesting interesting
things
and i would like to
you know
continue working there and uh
also do some books
you're originally from yugoslavia yes
where were you born in yugoslavia and
when did you leave
i was
born in a town called sarajevo
but my my my family comes from
montenegro
which is sort of the mountainous part of
the country in the south
and i left first yugoslavia when i was
12 years old 13.
what was the purpose of my my
my relatives came
my grandfather came to this country
at the turn of the century and
[Music]
when there was no yugoslavia and some of
my relatives came uh
before world war one
for us woodrow wilson was always a great
hero
uh
after the after world war ii uh
situation yugoslavia was rather bad
it's a poor country
and
[Music]
i had relatives here and i you know i
wanted to i came to to go to school here
and i went through school here maybe
this is not a fair question but why
would somebody buy this book compared to
all the other books on gorbachev what
have you done special here
i don't know what
other books on gorbachev they are
because i'm not familiar with them
[Music]
but
what is special is that
you know my co-author and i between us
have spent about uh
15 years together in the soviet union
we have
studied the country i speak the language
and i spend a lot of time actually doing
uh
work and trying to figure out what makes
this guy
tick
i think the book has more information as
i said i don't know of any other
biography about gorbachev that exists
today
um
and
we have some interesting things about
gorbachev we found out some interesting
things that you know give you an insight
into his character
name one
i think
for instance one of the interesting
things would be that
his grandfather was
served nine years in gulag
you know he comes from an area
of stavropol which was
[Music]
an area where
was free
most russians uh 95 of the russians were
serfs until
alexander the second abolish served them
in
1862.
but there was
russian peasants who lived along the
edges of the empire and were given
freedom
in order to render service to the empire
and defend the country the borders and
so forth and
these are quite different kinds of
people
the serve a surf mentality
i mean the people who are free have a
different mentality
comes from
a stock of free peasants and i think you
can see in his behavior that he behaves
differently from other soviet leaders
it's free in a way
uh his grandfather was in in 1931 there
was a famine because
the whole country was being forcibly
collectivized and the peasants
represented that
and particularly this farm belt where he
comes from in the ukraine
and millions of people were sent into
bulldogs or shot or whatever
on various pretexts
i'm not sure exactly what the charge
against
andre gorbachev was
but
i've heard a couple of versions and one
one was that he stashed away some food
because the government was
requisitioning food by force
just you have to give away all your
wheat
and of course peasants wanted to have
some wheat for their families and
and they burned the meat they
slaughtered
the animals and so forth just in
defiance
uh he could have been denounced by
somebody and because it was common in
those days so
but i think it's important in formation
of gorbachev i find it as a central
aspect of his character that early on
from his own family background from
stories that he heard from his
grandmother and parents
he knew of the injustices of the system
that that
his grandfather was sent for nine years
to to siberia for nothing
i think that
he probably
submerged this
sublimated as we say now
and i think that as an ambitious man and
he was an ambitious man from early on
he
he joined the party because this was the
only
venue to success
and
it's strange in the
in so in russia and you know in in in an
odd sort of way
communism has broadened the base for
political participation you know because
in cyrus russia
it was a class society where
political participation was restricted
to people a privileged class
while the communist society
opened up the base
you could join the party and move up
provided that you obey that you're like
a soldier
you're a soldier of the party
and i think he became a soldier of the
party and a good soldier
he
did what he was supposed to do
how many
brothers and sisters
does he have
he had two brothers one one was killed
at the battle of korsk
and the other one is about i think about
12 years younger and he became the apple
in his in his mother's eye and i think
that uh
it's all it's interesting that the
younger brother who is now an officer in
the soviet army
has not been a successful man
i mean his parents pampered him and
i wonder whether mikhail gorbachev
resented the fact or not i don't know
it's hard to tell but
but the younger brother is a lieutenant
colonel i'm told that
he doesn't see him often and when he
sees him it's in a formal setting
what about
president gorbachev's father
his father was not a communist he
although you know they tried to create a
myth that he was and because
in the official biography
it issued after gorbachev took charge
it says he supported the communist party
which means that uh
which implies that he was not against
the communists and so forth and
and he he was a mechanic with it you
know a farmer mechanic with tractors and
so forth his mother was a religious
person and then he he was baptized
i think that also had an impact on
gorbachev
at least later on because
he understood the diversity of views you
know
stalin was a was a seminarian i mean he
was he was trained to become a priest
but he turned against the religion as
sort of a vitriol in a violent way
while gorbachev had not done that and
and
during his tenure in office actually the
church became respectable
and
one of the mainstays of his political
support
and you know in china where i live now
we get soviet television just like here
just turn it on
and
it's staggering to see how you know
change in programming after the main
newscast in the evening for instance a
priest would come for 20 minutes
delivering a sermon on charity
you know
having lived there before and you've
been exposed to this for a long time i
was corresponding there for the first
time in from 68 to 71.
entirely different times i mean
the changes are staggering and i and
i think again
i happen to believe that uh individuals
do play an important role in history and
this is why it was interesting to
for me to kind of try to understand
who this guy is and where he comes from
you live now in beijing yeah and you
watch soviet television yeah
why did they put soviet television into
beijing they don't put it on and it says
joe you just get a
20 attachment to the antenna
and it's the water is closed you know so
it's flat so you can
you pick up soviet television
just like any other channel this is
really off mark but i read here a couple
weeks ago that robert shuler is now seen
in the soviet union his
religious service out of california have
you seen that i haven't seen that but
all sorts of things are possible now i
mean the soviet television has become
like
like cbs 60 minutes
i mean they go up
it's really amazing change
and uh
you speak russian oh yes
so you can understand everything that
comes across that i mean i'm fluent in
russian
i don't speak english what are the what
are the things you see on russian
television that amaze you
well
you know once you lift the restrictions
i mean it's it's sort of a normal
investigative program
because for such a long time
people
have been fed the
you know
propaganda
where people
people don't talk normally i mean and
now they talk normally and tell you what
they think
maybe not all but half of them do
i mean even when you go and do reporting
in moscow now you stop somebody in the
street and you know
it's a 50 50 chance that he'll tell you
exactly what he thinks
so in that sense i think gorbachev has
been a liberating force i mean
this glasnost
is not exactly freedom of the press
because uh the soviet union is not a
legal society
in other words it lacks this kind of
legal constitutional infrastructure
which you cannot develop
in five years i don't think it's
possible and if you look at in terms of
american educational systems
people are here educated my son is
educated from
first grade you know in certain
processes and so forth
the soviets don't have that so i think
they're trying to develop that but
coming back again to the to the press
he has opened up the press i mean
they've stopped
lying in a blatant way
back to
the early years
he grew up in stavropol how long did he
stay there
well he stayed there till he was 19 and
you know he's
he was an actor that he was very active
in the drama group and he played leading
roles in
school
theater
and
by all accounts he was a good actor
and he considered going to drama school
in moscow
but uh
he was an ambitious man and you know
from his girlfriend the first girlfriend
you could see that uh
that this man was bent hell-bent to
succeed
because his first girlfriend was of the
same age and she was a
daughter of a
local teacher but she was one grade up
in school and so she first went to
moscow to study and she
she founded
the pressure there too much and she
returned
and she said later that she always felt
that
gorbachev held that against her that she
she was not steely enough to endure
and uh and of course raisa is quite a
different type of girlfriend i mean a
woman afterwards because she's really
tough and determined knows what she
wants
but
his classmates at
moscow also said that he was a man who
studied hard and really got good grades
and so forth but
he wanted to become a public you know he
wanted a career in politics did you go
to stavropol in your research time yes
talk to people that knew him when he was
younger
i see when i went to stavropol actually
they didn't let people talk i mean i did
talk to some people who knew him there
but it was
at that point they did not really want
to talk that much
and even today for instance we don't
know
uh
some of the basic things about his life
because
of course you know all people say nice
things now it's very hard to kind of
figure out exactly what he lived in a
mud hut a three three room mud hut now
now there's a home which is sort of a
decent house where his mother lives
i think that
gorbachev has been
attached to his family he used to go
every year to
to his village on his birthday
and
and i believe that
the style of
russian
government is such that once you reach
the
throne you become the tsar
it's improper
to
talk about the past i mean it's in you
know it's entirely different from
american political system where we want
to know everything about uh
the political leader well lyndon johnson
will show the scar to princess margaret
as she comes up
there the from
formal uh setting is very important
because of their you know political and
historical traditions how far is
stavropol from moscow
styrofoam is about
1200 miles from moscow and it's a
wonderful place because it's
it's full of mountains and lakes and
wild rivers
it has captured the imagination of
the russians you know from 19th century
on tolstoy lerman pushkin all went down
there you have wonderful stories and
novels about
this this place where you have wild
muslim tribes and
you know
veiled women and
passion and
subtropical climate that's exotic for
the russians
and uh
it was a great fortune for gorbachev
actually to to be the leader of star
report in star report they're more sheep
than
people
it's a you know
sheep grazing area
but it's so beautiful that most of the
russian leaders like to vacation there
and once he became the leader of
stavropol the local governor so to speak
it was his duty to meet all these
dignitaries and play hosts
and
as you know and even in our business you
know if i'm a correspondent somewhere
you know if my owner and editor-in-chief
comes you know i'm his host and a
country guy
i can gain more access that way than any
i can i cannot see these people in
washington
but they're on your turf there so you
can actually establish rapport and
gorbachev established rapport with these
people and he was
skillful enough and charming he's a
charming guy
he knows how to turn on charm
uh
and they liked him and
the patronage and dropper was especially
important for him because he liked him
he saw a man of uh
you know imagination
willingness to work non-corrupt
and
promoted him
before we get to mr andropov
he left
stavropol when he was 19 where'd he go
he went to moscow he studied in moscow
for five years
and moscow was a place at that time in
the last years of stalin uh
i think that uh
this is the peak of stalin's cult of
personality
uh
where people actually
belie you know i see he had a status of
a
semi-gods so to speak
gorbachev became immediately active in
communist party youth organization and
he joined the party
when he was 21.
there
there's there no i have not heard of any
tales of gorbachev being a nasty
person or denouncing people or stuff
like that it seems to me that
he was fairly straight linage the czech
a former czech communist who was
lived in the same dormitory with him
and who became his friend where in
moscow
at the university
describes him as a decent man that
fundamentally
anti-stalinist not in terms of being
against stalin but anti-stalinist in
terms of not
against this totalitarian sway of mind i
mean it was not
he was not
a man who would do just anything to
get himself
to claw his way up the ladder
so
five years in studying in moscow then
what
he
he
he's studying he got an award for
neatness in moscow university which is
you know it also tells you something
about this uh
about his character that uh here's a guy
from
from stavropol who's and not even
startup was a town he's from a village
and he has made it to the capitol
and
he gets an award it's a big university i
don't i i believe at that time probably
forty thousand fifty thousand students
and he gets an award
for neatness his room is the neatest
along with a couple of other guys
i mean that's the first public mention
of gorbachev in the press
uh
before that he had received the the the
kalinin prize
in stavropol which was the number two
then the highest one was stalin and
colleen was the president at that time
figurehead president but that was the
number two slot
so he he does you know there's neatness
there's a neatness in his he's got an
organized intellect in a way
and if there's a flaw in his intellect
you could have you could see it even at
that time because he actually was very
sure and cocky of himself his girlfriend
for instance mentions that
even in high school
he
there was a teacher that didn't
teach properly somehow
and that gorbachev actually got so angry
to tell the teacher that he got it mend
his way otherwise he can lose his
certificate
but he was sure he felt that he was
unsure grounded you know to say that
there's something of a boy scout about
him you know that
there's an element of self-righteousness
also he he wants to do the right thing
he wants to be
correct he wants he always there was
always in his character that
and at moscow
you know he worked with people he worked
well and he there he met the guy who's
now his vice president okiana was in law
school too
the choice of law school was interesting
why would a guy from stavropol go to law
school and in those days uh
in those days
law had no meaning in stalin's russia
law was law was what stalin said
said law was
and even then it was violated
know they took people
in the middle of the night they pick up
the guy and they
without
any pro due process you are sent to jail
i i remember there was a there's a
famous uh
now dead writer
edmund who told me when they picked him
up
during stalin he didn't even ask what he
was signing and coveted the kgb of the
time came
so you sign here sign take him out send
him to tashkent
next
so why why did he choose law
i have no idea he said he wanted to go
to drama he considered several other
alternatives he chose law perhaps
because lenin was the law a
lawyer he studied law and perhaps he
thought this was a way to
to
get broader political education which
was right i don't believe that at that
time he was preoccupied with legalistic
from you know
he had no he didn't think in terms of
having a
soviet union becoming a legal uh you
know
a
society run by
laws and not by man by the way did you
interview his girlfriend
no you keep referring to her i wonder
where you would where you learned what
she had to say about him
david remnick of the washington post
interviewed and i i used his material
for that particular girlfriend
and i give him credit in the book
the
so i went to law school i'm not sure but
at any rate it was a good thing because
though in the law school was the only
place at moscow university where
he would be exposed to
books and authors other than marxist
leninist nonsense
because he had to learn latin
he had to read roman law i had to read
different yet he had to be aware of
different kinds of law
laws that existed
machiato read machiavelli mills hobbs so
forth
and
why did he decide then to go from
moscow to stavropol
when he could have a promising career in
moscow and bureaucracy is also
interesting he went back home in other
words he went back home at what age
after he finished he was 23. what was
his first job when he went back
he went in into the communist party uh
youth organization
and how long did it take him to be
noticed by
former
long time because uh
because he had to work his way up
so
what's interesting about him and raisa
is that they they went to
when did they marry they married in the
last year of uh their studies in moscow
that's in 1954.
in 1955 they went to startup
and
the
the uh
while there while they're in stavropol
see he
he decided he wanted to go to
agricultural college
and uh attended agricultural school at
night and got a degree after three years
and she
did her phd dissertation
and i've looked at her dissertation
actually because it's available
at the learning library in moscow
and
it's it's a it's a sociological study
above average i would say for an
american
college
where she divides her own questionnaire
and went around these uh collective
forms to figure out what you know about
traditions how they break down and so
forth
uh
it shows intellectual ambition on the
part of both her and him when do they
have children and how many do they have
they have one daughter and
i think it was she's
she's now married and have two
grandchildren
her
husband is is a doctor she's a doctor
they
her husband is jewish so they don't
publicize the name
because in russia that's not
an asset i guess
but
i think gorbachev
and raisa
showed an intellectual
sort of curiosity of mine that was
amazing and then for some reason they
also traveled when they were in
stavropol
which i think
also explains something about gorbachev
today because
in the in the 60s when he was a minor
official they went on a trip to france
and then on another occasion they went
on a trip to italy
and um
so
not as part of official delegation but
as
guests of local communists
which means a simple people there and so
forth so they could see real life in the
west
and i think that gorbachev saw
and could compare
france and italy with the soviet union
and
i think those trips have made an impact
on his mind
the previous soviet leaders never
traveled anywhere
and dropovers never left i mean and
dropper was in hungary's ambassador but
this was a part of the empire
i mean brezhnev never left until he
became the leader never
left the confines of his country neither
chennai called
so
this guy had you know been around and
seen things
intellectually curious
his wife is quite
you know she's curious and
intelligent interest in books
which is not an asset when when you deal
with foreign politicians because you
know she gets involved in
sometimes in fairly sophisticated and
she asked margaret thatcher you know
you know somehow they start talking and
she was interested in the in the
in the
the structure in i think cp snow's
novels
iris murdoch i've not forgotten which
one now
but she was interested in in a topic
that margaret you know margaret thatcher
was not interested and never thought of
i think
he's a politician dealing with
different kinds of issues
i think
that they didn't get most soviet
officials get to be you know enjoy
liquor
provincial life is boring
a governor enjoys vast powers in soviet
doing the provinces he's like a viceroy
and these two
did not succumb to temptation of
becoming either drunkards or something
but they went to school
it tells you something about it maybe it
also tells um you know there's an other
sign the flip side to this and that is
that
there's this burning ambition on the
part of people who are really uh still
provincials
and who have to prove themselves
and i've heard comments from people who
have gone to school with him
who say that
they always had a feeling that gorbachev
was
like a provincial actor who came to
moscow
and who was on the stage and it was very
good but he always had to do a little
extra to prove himself to show that he
is worthy
uh maybe that's the fourth that that's
the force behind that's the drive that
she's driving on
when did he
leave stavropol and go back to moscow
he was in stavapo for 23 years and in
1978 in november of 78
he was uh called to moscow
and there's there's an interesting you
know the way the patronage in politics
works i guess in every country so but
but that summer
and dropper was pushing him to come to
moscow and but you have to get approval
of
brezhnev who was then the party leader
and there's a meeting in fact this is
one of those things that if you do
research you come across
strange things
that
at the railroad station and
i've forgotten the name of the place
down
south in stavropol or mineral nevada
which is in stavropon at the railroad
station
you had a meeting between brezhnev
cineco
andropov and gorbachev and this was i
believe in july of 1978 the four future
leaders
because
chanyenko and brezhnev were on the train
by going by train to
uh
some place and they stopped off and and
drop off and and uh
gorbachev joined them
because androppa wanted to introduce his
prodigy
to them and get their approval
and then
later that year by november
gorbachev was appointed
secretary of central committee in charge
of agriculture
step back though and tell us when
the end drop-off gorbachev connection
was made
the connection was made
sometimes after 1970 when gorbachev
became
first secretary of the stavropo region
which means local government and and
drop off
with kidney problems and
always used to go to mineral nevada
which means mineral waters you know it's
a spa down there which is very pretty
and
he this guy would meet him and addre was
the second was the chairman of the kgb
i think
[Music]
i've i've i've
studied mr andropov so i know a little
bit about how he also operated i think
he checked this guy out very well
because
he wouldn't have con
put his trust in him
if he there was something shady in his
background
because andropov in a sense was also
puritan and he wanted to get people who
were not corrupt around him
and
but i think that mr gorbachev has also
realized at that point
that he he is one of the most powerful
people in the country
who
took a liking to him and that he had to
exploit it also
there was his connection
and i i believe he must have done
you know he must have
talked to andropov and they established
this intellectual rapport which
i think was essential to it to garbage
rise to power and which helped him once
he was in power because he inherited the
support of the undropper of constituency
at least part of the kgb was
he remains with
gormachob
the intellectuals who were unhappy the
people wanted to change i mean that
constituency that formed around and drop
of
gorbachev inherited that
what what was mr andropov all about
he's an enigmatic figure i think you
know
it's very difficult to talk about a man
who was who was head of a
of a nasty organization for 15 years
and
the
i know people were very close to him and
who said that
they
one thing that they felt bad about was
that he stayed with kgb for such a long
time
um
on the other hand
you
you can judge
you know we don't
mr bush was with ci for a year but i
don't think it's quite the equivalent
and also one year is nothing you know
i believe in political leadership of
such organizations that
they're involved in nasty businesses
but 15 years a long time you begin to
think like people you you work with and
you develop i guess an instinct for
you know back to a maneuver for
on the other hand kgb was an
organization that had a detailed picture
of the disaster situation in the soviet
union and the need for change
and
i think that judging then andropov as
the political leader
once he becomes secretary and president
of the soviet union
you have to judge him not in terms of uh
you know
whether he was this or that and whatever
but
what kind of a concept of the country he
had and its place in the world what
should be done and so forth and in that
context andropov is the man who started
the reforms of the soviet union because
he was the first one who told them the
truth
but they they didn't know what they were
doing
but things have to change this is not
the rational way of doing things how
long was he head of the country
very short time in about a year and a
half less than a year and a half
and during that period he promoted
gorbachev to the number two slot
because half of the time he was sick
and
so gorbachev became heir apparent
by virtue of his connection to the top
leader
but without really the clout and
prestige in the in the in the top
councils of the country and that's why
the the old guard was able to make this
last stand
and election was sort of a
nice old man but
without a single idea in his head i mean
new idea or something competent
bureaucrat but not not imaginative at
all
and it was gorbachev's like fortune that
shanienko didn't live more than a year
so that
again the country faced this you know
the succession of people dying i mean
this is it's traumatic for a big big
country
uh
i
but once he you know
he he took over and drop-offs
constituency in andropovs program
but then he pushed with far greater
vigor than anybody suspected and i think
that had
any of the soviet leaders at the time
who voted for
gorbachev
anticipated what this man was going to
do
they would have never put him in that
job
because you know he has practically
destroyed communism
you think he's consciously
doing what he's doing
with a purpose
i i think that he
i think that he came as a man who wanted
to change and give a human face to
socialism
i think that he still believes that he's
doing the right thing and i i think that
when he says he's a communist he still
believes he's a communist
but it's a different kind of communism
i mean he
he believes
i think that the peak of his career
is
when february of this year he
had
the
central committee of the communist party
formally vote to abandon
its you know monopolistic grip and power
i mean you have an emergence of
pluralism
and
it's a tragedy of you know it's it's
doing a story of doing a biography of
gorbachev is
like writing a novel
of a man who starts out with a
high-minded purpose
and who encounters a series of
calamities man-made or natural you know
i take chernobyl
because it's it's such an enormous cost
on them
economic costs you want to
revive a marbling economy and then comes
chernobyl then comes the armenian
disaster and
the earthquake
then you know he
lets loose he makes uh
lithuanian independence possible
see the very people who benefit most
from gorbachev
will destroy him
it's inevitable i mean he's almost like
like a doomed figure because he cannot
uh you know
the very forces he unleashed
uh
now he cannot stop anymore
he wants to create a new kind of
federalism i mean i think it's an
important subject it's got so hard to
you know the the federalism of soviet
union as as we have known it for the
last 70 years is a fraudulent federal
federalist it's based on coercion you
know you grab a piece of real estate put
your people there and you say we are fed
you know this is a republic
and i
i believe that he
had realized that
but i think he had realized that only
after he had come to power
i think that he has realized so many
things are the under pressure of events
because
obviously
he is not reacting to events
he's no longer leading them
he's he's trying to channel them in in
direction
his greatest successes were in foreign
policy because this is an area where you
can use imagination when he can and a
few people can come and sit down and
make decisions
but
when you come to the economy and the
question of nationalities
you know these are intractable problems
what do you do
do you have any personal friends
i think his closest friend is raisa
and it's intro you know
this also tells you something about
kremlin politics it's like being in a
snake pit because all these guys are
around you have to constantly watch all
sides and i've watched them work
because
you know in politics you can buy brains
you can't buy trust
and see raisa is the person who watches
other people what because you know i'm
talking to you and i have to talk and
react but i cannot see the reactions see
she's the one who sees reactions and he
consults with her you know
and it's a very touchy issue in the
soviet union when tom brocko had an
interview with him
and the only question that was not
broadcast on soviet television
was when he asked him about race and
whether he consulted with her
matters of state and he said yes
but that was eliminated from the
interview
who are his closest advisors his closest
friend and advisor is jakoblev and it's
interesting here it's interesting
uh how
jacob lives experience in in canada and
in in the united states
made an enormous impact on his mind
because jacob
was the first soviet exchange student
who came to colombia in 1959 spent the
year at colombia
and
i think that our people have always sort
of mis misjudged the oculus and there
was it was always previously labeled as
being anti-american but you know if
you're in soviet politics
and if you have enemies and you have
studied at colombia for a year it's
always easy to accuse you of being
pro-american so yaakov has always
publicly taken a position
that was critical of the united states i
guess to protect himself because his
cast of mind is not that way but then he
was exiled to canada as ambassador for
10 years
and we spent i spent three hours with
the acura one day talking to him
and because i covered canada for a year
for the washington post just at the time
when he was ambassador there
so we were talking about
canada
he remembered the names of trudeau's so
i mean he knew everybody and then he was
telling me how
you know how much he liked trudeau he
said they would spend time never talking
politics but discussing pushkin and
dostoyevsky
philosophy
and
i think that and again you know the the
the incidents and personalities how they
play these things first trip that
gorbachev made was to canada
first trip when he was the number two
man
that was while and dropper was still
alive he made a trip to canada and jacob
live was an ambassador to canada
and he had six days in canada and seven
days
and yakula was his escort
and
they talked about things he saw canada
he saw canada
and canada for the russians is sort of
an except see they always see themselves
as competitors to the united states so
it's very hard for them to
kind of
see united states accepting this
adversarial position but canada was a
country that's different big country
also
but different
and they you know they they went to
these farms and here's a gorbachev
agricultural expert and he sees what the
canadians do he's fascinated
it's unbelievable
because the russians cannot feed
themselves why
look just just one fact i can tell you
that in the 70s from 1970 to 1980 10
year period
the import of
agricultural goods
is increased tenfold in 1970 it's 800 a
year and 800 million dollars
of imports
in
1980 it's 7.2 billion dollars
it's it's it's enormous thing
why
and guarantor goes to canada sees you
know that how how this works and you
know canadians have fantastic
agriculture
and they've also you know
when you come to the united states the
americans have a tendency to proselytize
the canadians are not that way
they show him here see
he was fascinated and he was fascinated
by yaakov because jacqueline is an
intelligent guy
and to them it looked like you know they
know their domestic troubles and all
that and they know what
they're in deep trouble
and they have to look for a way out and
obviously they have to go to the market
there's no other way
but how do you if you're if you're a
political leader how do you move
from
central planning you know this has been
inculcated in people's minds
to market means chaos
means that what they have been
denouncing for years
all of a sudden becomes official policy
is your book going to be published in
the soviet union
i wish it would be about see shadows
this was my previous book was not
published there it was published in
china by the way is there any book like
yours that's published in the soviet
union
i don't think so
you have a co-author louise branson who
is she
she worked for the sunday times
london
and uh
she has spent six years in in the soviet
union
the russian special she taught for a
year at the
at
the institute of
steel in moscow
and then worked for five years as a
correspondent
how did you divide up your
responsibilities
well it was an interesting i mean i
would never go through it again but it
was an
interesting collaboration because we
have
i'm to the left of the political
spectrum and she is to the right of
attila the hun
and so we had to argue some things uh
when when it came to
you know assessments of situations but
uh i think on the whole it's beneficial
to
to have different points of view and
kind of mesh them where is she now
she's here in town she's in china too
is there any way to know what this man
is like in his private moments what does
he do when he has free time
i think he's a workaholic
i think he doesn't enjoy fun
i think he's he's a man who's obsessed
with a mission
uh i think he's uh
taken upon himself
more than
a normal human being can take on himself
how long will he last
and
i think even the weatherman is wrong 50
of the time on things like this
i would say that he cannot last very
long because uh
i think perestroika is dead
uh
i think he's flogging a dead horse now
because
you have to start all over again you
have to destroy what you know the system
and build it anew
and he's in a way a very tragic figure
for me
i i actually you know once you do this
you begin to sympathize with the guy
particularly gorbachev is a likable guy
and the odds are against him all odds
are against him
and he's got
but i think that that he has wrought a
change in the world
i mean he's freed eastern europe i mean
if nothing else
he is
he has demolished the communist myth
i mean this whole century has been
obsessed by communism from 1905 in first
russian revolution
in 1917 when the bolshevik seized power
ever since we have been obsessed by
communism in their spread
and here under gorbachev he presides
over and he
initiates
demise of communism as such
there's only in china now
comes
in albania
if he's going to go how will he go
i i think that his greatest problem is
that he has not delivered meat and
potatoes
and people vote with their pocketbooks
i mean
and there are people around who are you
know who's saying read my lips you know
no price increases no sacrifice yeltsin
is that
uh they're the armed forces they're very
uncomfortable with this man because the
situation in the strategic situation for
him is disastrous i mean
in europe you know
nato exists and our problem is to give
nato a mission because there's no warsaw
pact
but for him problem is that there is no
warsaw power
and
i don't know how
you know how strong that military
pressure is going to be but i think he
has to watch
because the soldiers are unhappy that
he's using the army and the quell
domestic
unrest
to keep you know azerbaijan armenia
baltics and quiet i mean they're unhappy
they don't want to be a police force
how's it going to go
i get i think it's that this winter is
critical for him and uh
he he's not a quitter although he has
offered three times to quit
but he has offered three times to quit i
i take this as an act of courage he's an
extremely courageous man
he's and it's not like al haig offering
to quit and hoping you know
he'll be turned down but i think that
he said he knows only one way how to do
it and if they don't like it that way
they should find somebody else
he's got one way to do it he's got one
plan
he's got one vision
he's not going to stay in power simply
to stay in power that that's
he may change
if he quits
how do they get their next leader
i think that there's a batch of new
people emerging who are who are quite
interesting and so but i'll tell you one
thing soviet union is no longer a
superpower that's a problem for us
because
you know
if you want to have superpowers you have
to have two
there's a game you can't play with the
i think are creating now a super power
of soviet union it's a country that's in
enormously troubled
the empire is gone
i mean mr you know mr bush speaks for
the west when he talks to somebody
we have allies we have solid
relationships
we may not always agree but i mean we
basically share certain
you know
volume of common ideas and interests
and mr gorbachev represents only soviet
union now and even within soviet union
but let's say quits or
ousted or what i'm getting at is there
ever going to be a free election for the
president of the soviet union
i think you already have an emergence of
pluralism just the very fact that you
have yeltsin
i mean we say oh big challenge
it's a consequence of changes politic
even extremely successful in making
political changes in the soviet union
let me ask a different way because we're
running out of time
do you ever envision the possibility
that we wake up one day the military's
taken over
everything changes glasnost is out the
window
and they're back to where they were a
couple years ago yeah i can see that
scenario yes can you see them moving
back into eastern europe no
no
i i can see the scenario where they can
go back
and stop the momentum of change on
glasnost and so forth but that can be a
temporary measure you know the soldiers
cannot
soldiers are very bad politicians they
don't know how to do things
and it seems to me that
you know
ideas are important i think freedom is a
measure of power i've always argued that
but ideas are important see as long as
people believed in that there's
something like you know future happiness
utopia and so forth they supported the
system even reluctantly maybe even but
somehow
that's gone unfair probably but
in 10 years predict what the soviet
union will be all about
i i think in 10 years in 10 years soviet
union probably will be a second great
power
how will it be governed i think that
it's going to emerge towards some kind
of a
pluralistic society
it will take more than a generation to
evolve towards democracy because there's
no infrastructure but there's a movement
in that direction i have no doubt about
our guest for the last hour has been the
author of the new book gorbachev heretic
and the kremlin
descoder former washington post reporter
u.s news and world report
bureau chief in beijing now a freelancer
still living in china thank you for
joining
[Music]
us join us next week on booknotes for a
conversation with scholar thomas sowell
of the hoover institution his new book
preferential policies and international
perspective
examines the impact of government
mandated preferences on society and its
role in heightening ethnic polarization
that's book notes next sunday at 8 pm
eastern time 5 p.m for our west coast
viewers
coming up next a bbc radio call and